il pousse actuellement de drôle de
structure sur la parcelle de marek dans
les marais de bourges
en plus de la jussie défaut ces artistes
photographes designers commencent à
occuper l'espace
c'est une terre très très riche tout
pousse mais aussi des mauvaises herbes
donc il faut pour y être tout le temps
mais c'est aussi la détente c'est le
bonheur d'être dans la nature et de
devoir tout poussé d'intervenir voilà
les interventions humaines dans le
paysage c'est le sujet de la conférence
du célèbre jardinier gilles clément
samedi
c'est aussi ce qu'ont décliner les
artistes comme jean louis radiguet et sa
drôle de maison on s'approche de cette
maison d'abord on sait pas que c'est une
maison
ensuite on sait qu'on est dans la maison
parce qu'on voit le sol donc là du coup
on regarde autour de nous on pivote à
360 et on voit des murs effectivement
des murs décomposer c'est le principe
est on voit l'extérieur aussi ce qui
fait qu'à un moment donné dans l'idée on
ne sait plus si on est à l'intérieur ou
à l'extérieur
michael ryder artiste australien qui vit
à jérusalem a imaginé un cocon à la fois
chrysalide géante et refuge protecteur
le cocon est une structure faite à
partir de matériaux locaux
il raconte un système de construction
naumann le cocon évoque les
métamorphoses qui s'y déroulent
on y entre dans un certain état et grâce
à la contemplation
on en ressort transformé michel aulas d'
a décidé de reconstruire avec des
photographies géantes le mur de
jérusalem qui sépare israël et la
palestine
ça c'est un dessin de vence qui
laulan c'est ça qu'ils font c'est le
lanceur c'est un anti intifada avec des
fleurs au milieu de l'immense mur de
photos tendu un checkpoint sépare le
jardin en deux donc c'est ce qui arrive
à pas mal de palestiniens qui ont des
champs d oliviers voir des animaux à 20
mètres de chez eux c'est-à-dire leur
maison et là le mur est là et de l'autre
côté il ya les oliviers mais il doit
faire cinq kilomètres des fois pour
aller à checkpoint pour pouvoir aller de
l'autre côté
l'exposition une saison dans les marais
l'automne sera visible du 15 septembre
au 15 décembre dans les marais de
bourges